we all know these people who are still
bamboozled who are still trying to break
out of their factory settings
but they can be gotten to i really
believe it there's not many people who
can move one way or another who are
going to potentially vote in a different
way this november than they would have
in the past but i think the democrats
who are not completely
mind-melted at this point are the ones
that we can get to
and one of them is tulsi gabbard we need
a
unifying president someone who will
bring our country together and
unfortunately what we're seeing from
president biden and his administration's
exact opposite
they are pouring fuel on the flames of
divisiveness they are attacking and
targeting anyone who dared to vote
against president biden or anyone who
dares to disagree with his views
demonizing them and and frankly
portraying them as extremists who pose a
very direct threat uh to our country
it's clear that through his speech
through his actions and policies
he cares more about power than he does
about the freedom and well-being of the
american people
i mean i've said it a bajillion times
but just imagine what a different
situation we might be in
if the democrats when they cut all the
backdoor deals had gone with tulsi as vp
instead of kamala harris imagine what a
moderating effect that might have had
and when they put that woman out an
active member of our military who's a
proud american
who is more lefty than i am
uh
imagine how different that would be than
when they put out kamala who has no idea
what she's saying i mean it would be so
fundamentally different that would have
been the chance but the point is they
always miss their chance and you know
why because they've become the party of
no common sense but who said that it
wasn't me oh that was bill maher i think
they're going to get
thumped in the election i mean that
usually happens in midterm elections but
you know i mean joe look i'm glad he's
there
but uh he has not exactly stuck the
landing on a lot of the issues that he
was dealing with i keep saying this to
the democratic party the reason why
you're so toxic is because you have
become the party of no common sense
well what do you mean you're glad he's
there what do you mean you're glad joe
biden's there are you glad
that we left afghanistan the way that we
did are you glad that the deficit is
through the roof are you glad that the
supply chain ain't working are you glad
that gas prices were through the roof
now they're coming down a little bit so
the administration is going see gas
prices are coming down but it's like
they're still higher than when you got
there okay fine that so many things are
a problem but you're glad he's there
meaning you're glad orange man isn't
there
and and that's what i'm gonna hopefully
work on a little bit uh with bill maher
but yes the democrats are no longer the
party of common sense perhaps they never
were but there is nothing
commonsensical about the democrats
anymore which is why i always say you
don't have to be a republican but you
cannot be a democrat these people all
have to go
and and if that means that the radical
base that the progressive woke lunatics
and the genderless whack-a-doodles and
all of that stuff that they fully take
over that party well then so be it
because they've taken it over already
and and some of the people who are the
quasi-moderates they're just making it
seem like it's not as bad as it is but
it is